and a foul Nicola yovich the rookie has
come in and look who's coming in Udonis
Haslam
who's going to retire after the season
after 20 years all with the Miami Heat
one of the great careers
and they're making him wait till the
second shot I would say this from a
common sense standpoint if Udonis Haslam
wants to come in on the first free throw
let him how about this one of the
players for the Denver Nuggets getting
ready to be inserted in the game has his
T-shirt on
not aware that he didn't
and just realized it
so all teams emptying their benches with
29.8 remaining Haslam comes in
a three-time champion and he was a
starter for those championship teams the
oldest player in the NBA at 42 he's
always has represented the very best of
the NBA he is heat culture and his
number will be retired in Miami and I
believe he had
or so in the last regular season game
when he got extended minutes and they
celebrated
[Applause]
his long career
he won't be celebrating he'll be
thinking about game four
living up the series as Denver was an
emphatic response here tonight Crown
wants him to shoot he does
[Music]
heard seven with a rebound